have some chocolate in my teeth
dark chocolate healthier all right so
we're gonna review American made today
starring one of my favorite actors of
all time you damn trucks so one of my
favorite actors of all time Thomas the
cruise so in this film Tom Cruise has a
terrible southern accent and it's based
on the true story of real-life pilot
Barry seal who I've never heard of until
I saw this movie he's sort of worked for
the CIA
he's sort of worked for Pablo Escobar
and he really did a lot of illegal
things like a lot of illegal things
before going into this movie I was
really thinking about how those ads of a
play before YouTube videos for this film
would say one of the best reviewed
movies of the fall which really isn't
saying a lot because fall has just begun
I notice a lot of people have been
comparing this movie to blow rightfully
so hey that rhymes yo because it's a
true story about an American guy who
helped bring cocaine into the United
States you guys don't know what cocaine
is it's the thing that helps me keep
this channel running but to me this
movie is really a strong cross between
the movie blow and the film Lord of war
I feel like a lot of people haven't seen
Lord of war it stars Nicolas Cage and
Jared Leto but it's another movie about
a guy getting corrupted by the American
Dream who was illegally dealing drugs to
African warlords and that film is
amazing by the way go watch and there's
a lot of movies about the corruption of
the American Dream that involves a
good-hearted man with a lot of financial
struggles then gets involved in this
drug business or a legal gun business
this movie has both with a lot of
stylized narration techniques films like
blow lord of war war dogs witcher all
films that are clearly inspired by
better made Scorsese films such as
Goodfellas Casino and wolf of Wall
Street well wolf of Wall Street came
later after a lot of those movies
whatever and this movie definitely falls
under the category of those kind of
films with some stuff being its own
thing and the main appeal of what made
this movie enjoyable is Thomas the
cruise ship and yeah man he really does
do a terrible southern accent I don't
think I could even tell on the trailer
that he was at
empty we got to a point where I was like
why do I even try now man you just can't
do it
but beyond the accent though beyond the
axe and his performance is still
wonderful the charisma and the heart of
his performance is what really carries
this film and he's pretty funny in it
too and it's one of those films that
requires an actor to provide a really
interesting narration voice over and he
does that very well and there's some
other pretty good performances in here
too Damo Gleeson he plays the man who
initially recruits Barry seal starts him
on this path and he's great at that like
charismatic yet suspicious behavior
sarah wright plays Barry seals hot wife
and I really believed the chemistry she
had with Tom Cruise and I thought their
scenes had more of the emotional stakes
and I wish more screentime was dedicated
to their relationship the thing that's
really at stake here is Barry seal
endangering his family or losing his
family and she oh my Tommy Cruise nails
a southern accent and in a way I felt
like her character had a more even
defined arc than Tom Cruise's character
which isn't a bad thing I think that's
great that they gave her that and
someone who I don't even think you see
in the trailer Caleb Landry Jones he was
that weird brother to the main girl in
the film get out and in this movie he's
playing another weird brother to the
main girl in the film and I think he's
great in the movie he plays a really
defining character and he's super
believable when he's on screen and the
actor alejandra Edie he plays one of the
main baddies of the cartel real-life
figure Jorge Ochoa and I think people
often reference Pablo Escobar being a
character in this movie because he's
arguably the most famous one to come out
of Colombia especially when narcos means
such a big hit but there's definitely
more screen time dedicated to Jorge than
there is to Pablo and I think this actor
does a fantastic job and has great
screen time with Tom Cruise so overall
there's great performances there's a lot
of 80s music but I definitely didn't
love this movie it has a really high
score on Rotten Tomatoes and in no way
shape or form do I hate this movie we're
I wouldn't even say I dislike this movie
I just really think it's the definition
of an okay fill like I think it's a
great film to watch to kill some time or
if you want to just catch up on some
more Tom Cruise filmography and even
though there's some like dangerous scene
sequences I think that it's actually one
of those films I would turn on while I'm
flying on a plane my main issue with
this movie is the dramatic weight the
stakes the conflicts there's it's not
really felt it like kind of come
and goes it's a little a bit of waves
and like Barry steel gets asked to take
part in this dangerous journey and a
fascinating journey while we're at it
that progressively gets more dangerous
as the film progresses yet most of the
film sort of just feels like Barry's
handling business it's fun it's amusing
but the conflicts and dangers for this
type of story are really lacking
whenever it seems like it's about to get
super intense or gripping it never quite
reaches that mark there are a few scenes
I can think of that have that but
overall the film doesn't have that for
me personally because most of the film's
is Barry making money and then making
more money and he has a business and
then the business is growing and he runs
into a couple obstacles but then he
handles business then he gets a little
more complicated but then looks on his
side and the direction and editing of
this film I'm kind of conflicted on
there's at times I like this style and
then there are other times where I
thought it was a little annoying
it's from director Doug Liman who did
films like mr. and mrs. Smith and the
Bourne Identity and it's like
filmography way back like swingers and
of course he did edge of tomorrow with
Tom Cruise which is a very good
companion piece to this movie and doug
liman i know that occasionally in his
films he likes to have his handheld
style and this movie is super handheld I
get it it's a true story
and usually handheld equals making the
audience feel like it's realistic but
the film has us like weird shifting and
editing between handheld realism and
superimposing close-ups and then random
super-stylish [ __ ] with clever angles
and crash zooms and pull backs then it
feels real and then suddenly there's
like cool narration tricks and editing
graphics it can just feel a little
choppy in a little uneven and because
it's a biopic of this dudes like crazy
adventure into corruption and you know
overall good luck II had well being in
this corruption business it covers a lot
of things and oftentimes with movies
like this I tend to feel this way
sometimes they can feel rushed and their
scenes are it's like it's not rushed but
like let this scene sink in a little bit
or slow damn just a tad don't get me
wrong I was always interested I just
wasn't ever fully pulled in the film was
a lot more of interesting things
happening with Tom Cruise giving an
entertaining performance watching him
get away with a lot of crazy [ __ ] and it
doesn't feel like till after Midway of
act two when some intense
The Situation's really start to be felt
I mean that's really all I can say about
this film it's interesting it's
enjoyable and overall entertaining but
unlike films that it's similar to like
blow or bore dogs or Goodfellas those
films are very similar in style and
storytelling to this movie because those
films are also interesting enjoyable and
entertaining but those movies had
qualities that I didn't feel this film
really possessed such as gripping
engaging and emotional I mean one thing
I did like about this film that I felt
made it stand out a little bit more is
that while its structure is a little bit
predictable you know the rise in the
fall it's like how it goes with any of
these corruption types of movies there's
some cliches I felt that steered away
from I don't want to feel like this
movie gave in to having Barry seal be a
man who just loses sight of everything
that he really values looses his heart
his humanity his soul in the process
like when this film starts out you can
see he's a working pilot who just really
loves his wife and children and I like
that aspect I feel like a lot of the
time it's a guy maybe has a girlfriend
or he's single and then along the way of
a gathering riches he finally gets a
woman and then he goes down this path
here it starts off where he's just a
dude who already has a family that he
really loves he's already a really good
guy and he never seems to lose that
heart he just wants to be successful and
provide for his family and spoil them a
little bit what man wouldn't want to do
that so Barry's never portrayed as a man
turned into a bad guy cuz even though he
deals with bad people
the film never got to a point for me
where I'm like Barry seal was a bad dude
if I were to recommend it I would say
it's worth checking out when it's on
blu-ray or waiting for a streaming
service or waiting for it to be on an
airplane the next time you're flying
because it's lack of strong emotional
engagement attracts a lot of what could
have made this film a powerful
entertaining experience I mean two
people fell asleep behind me right
behind me at a 7 p.m. show hey ya know
it's night time it's not that late I
mean it started snoring halfway through
the film my first thought was that's
kind of annoying my second thought was
well everything just seems to be kind of
working out for this guy whenever he's
in trouble Luck's on his side so there's
not really much danger to keep someone
awake sometimes but if you're a Tom
Cruise fan you're really gonna enjoy
this movie and if you're looking for
an entertaining film I'd say go watch it
I it's definitely not a bad movie by any
stretch it to me it's just okay any of
you guys you see American made where
would you put what would you rank it on
good movies of like blowing Goodfellas
and Wolf of Wall Street where would you
rank it subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell follow me
at the Greg alb on Instagram and Twitter
and go check out our patreon become a
patronage actor
[Music]